high breath i mean kylie man i've been
through periods in my life
where i thought i'm never going to write
anything else i mean just
couldn't it increasingly because i
started in 84
so this is my 36th year
i get writer's block less now than i did
even
15 20 years ago um
but like writing these punchline cards
last night
i'm sitting there with my wife and she's
watching tv but as she's gotten a little
older she puts the closed caption on so
she can read
that and it was a show set in ireland so
she's watching closed caption and
literally
as i'm watching i'm just reading the
closed caption reading words
you know and a word might be
confused you know and i'm sitting there
going what's what's a joke i can do with
confused
and it's
so it's just like little pings to
inspire me
i think it's great to have one or two
other comics
that as you have these ideas that you
can
and you get stuck that that you can go
to these other people and go hey
is there anything funny in this idea uh
i have a buddy scott dunn who lives in
nashville that
we just write well together and
you know there's times that i'll go to
scott and say is there anything funny in
this he said
i don't know he's honest or he'll go
yeah that's
that's a good premise let's see what we
can do with it you know so i'll write
jokes and i'll send them to him and
and he's like i don't like this part but
i think you're on the right track here
and so
find somebody that that you can that you
can write
with writing stud
that's all we are we're writers
people always ask me do you practice in
front of a mirror i said i've never
practiced performing
anything and performing is just
instinctual to me if i'm the kid in the
grocery store aisle
and a and i throw myself in the floor
and spin around that's not something i
practice it just
kind of just happened but the words
leading up to that
that's the heart i saw 25 years ago
steve martin won an award for
writing and he said out of everything
that he had won
you know academy awards or
golden globe he said this is the most
precious
award to me because writing is hard
wow right and and it
is you have to make yourself
do it mm-hmm you and and the blank
page or the blank computer screen scares
the crap out of all of us
and so you know nobody wakes up going
boy i want to write
but once you start once you get that
first sentence in
or at least i can only speak to me once
i begin
then it just kind of comes i mean
it's one of my favorite quotes from
christopher titus he says i hate writing
but love having written
that's that's that is perfect yeah
that is right and i will tell you you'll
never find a great
comedian that's not a great writer
so you want to be a great comedian you
better work on your writing
yeah yes